who was responsible
for this
the attack on the u.s capitol was
vicious and shocking
this trial has given us new insights
into the mayhem
the vice president and his family being
rushed from a hiding place as the mob
called for him to be hanged
republican senator mitt romney being
told to run away
but was all this really caused by the
words of one man
democrats have alleged that after years
of inflammatory rhetoric by donald trump
this was the moment that turned a
protest into a riot
you fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
mr trump's lawyers insist it's absurd to
blame
him for the attack on the capital the
article of impeachment now before the
senate
is an unjust and blatantly
unconstitutional
act of political vengeance
this is ordinary political rhetoric that
is virtually
indistinguishable from the language that
has been used
by people across the political spectrum
for
hundreds of years this is a fight
fighting
i say they mocked the idea that the word
fight could be so dangerous
with a long video of democrats using
exactly the same word
fight of their lives we are in this
fight for our lives
we cannot ever get up fighting
but democrat prosecutors here are
unrepentant in their caustic criticism
of the former president
and he has at every opportunity
encourage
and cultivated actual violence
by these groups yes he has encouraged
actual violence not just the word
fight mr trump has been in florida
playing golf but
also following events as they unfold in
the senate
you can still see the scars of that mob
attack here in washington dc
this fence was hastily erected it runs
for several miles with razor wire on top
and hundreds of troops on the other side
all here
to defend the capital the building
that was attacked but which now houses
the senators who will cast their verdict
on the future of donald trump
very few expect him to be convicted if
he were it would be
extraordinary america is waiting to see
what happens next
adam parsons sky news washington
you